20 seconds 15 seconds 50 players 1886
average rating get this ticker out of my
way I should have maybe gone for a
gambit oh okay is that gonna be a quick
win
click resign throw this pawn up on push
I jumped my knight in there let me lock
down on that open stuff up on that Queen
can resign it's a check just take here
no matter what the Knights pinned take
it next it's close to me don't take pin
pieces here where's that King go that's
double check pick up this night and then
where is the main take that that King is
Dane look at him he is crazy he is crazy
there we go wow that king went for a
walk
twos okay hang on regroup here regroup
the ending to that last term it did not
happen
clear your mind stay focused stay
focused is the plan
stay focused and be sneaky check man I
just still want to do it
Oh h2o yes a sneak attack a sneak attack
out of nowhere h2 strikes again again h2
man ok that always gets a little giggle
out of me if you didn't realize Age 2
just Sage to give me the bishop oh
they're in pre move mode pre move mode
it spawns a thorn gonna grab here I'm on
the rook I'm still on the rook
everything is falling pin the night and
then kill the night even if he's still
pinned get rid of the tricky Knight ASAP
centralize your knight jump in no okay
yeah cut the King off and now I want to
jump into what square f6 next no matter
what
natan one too unavoidable uh-oh chess
juggler okay back to chairman twelve
twelve six four two okay Oh apples
apples let's go with this I like the UH
I like this gambit all of a sudden just
all of a sudden it could be decline and
then it gets kind of dry okay f2 I was
really ready to try a quick Anton
squared tactic night here might be
pretty good all right let's keep my
bishops okay what's the story here
what's that story right there
well tonight it's telling the knight
pawn push I take the rook seems like
it's working out pretty good until that
one was played uh okay queenside castle
whoa drop back here there would be a
knight check and grab this pawn maybe
Bishop here I chased it off of that
diagonal play here again what am I
missing my pawns seeing something that
I'm not just seeing something okay back
to chairman 2019 maybe you thought that
night was on c5 okay 29:29 six six a lot
of time remaining Patriot chess before
okay
gain some space break down that pond oh
no oh man there was Queen h4 there
that's why I thought my opponent was
hesitating ah this is a nice center
isn't it it's a nice center if Queen e7
I have to come back I don't have castles
and rook e1 stuff I'm not controlling
you one just yet okay
which I think Bishop g4 was available I
want to give a check rook check oh this
is deadly very deadly I'm on the Queen
now get to save that bishop and take
this guy next seems like it's me Queen
here I should have done that and then
discovered tricks that's just me that
was a help me back to tournament 38 and
that was that was the only square the
King had on his home square okay hang on
hang on this is the guy I played in the
first round right tempo gainer gained
some space
push the Knights around push this night
around support my furthest advance pawn
lock like this how do they complete
their development its position is
opening up they're not castled
discovered discovered stuff move the
knight yeah it's gonna be dangerous
it's check Knight check tricky Knights
discovered check double check I get the
rook anything better not seeing it
rescue my knight Bishop to f5 bishops
function well on two adjacent diagonals
Bishop here is lethal isn't it
not quite yeah let's take this Knight
another check right around the corner
Knight see - he's coming back another
check he's not finished he's not
finished another check he is not
finished yet more checks more checks
finally mate more checks man where's
this King going why can't I find me just
go here get my last piece involved it's
gotta be another check where is this me
take the rook maybe why not just take
the rook another check this King is
ridiculous
is this gonna be mate yet wow that was
like a record number discovered checks
wasn't it this has got to be mate now
finally how many matin ones a time is
give me a tally okay if you're watching
this on youtube i'm sure you'll you'll
let me know let me know where my faults
are okay
stay focused no time for laughing stare
at those squares stare at those squares
okay be more aggressive but your bishop
what's the matter with you be more
aggressive play d6 and claim a thorn
claim a thorn claim a queen what does
claim authority mean starting to say
stuff that doesn't make sense not just
starting I'm continuing I'm continuing
to say stuff that doesn't mean anything
am I here
tricky Forks tricky discoveries oh I
should have just given check check check
where's the me
hang on got something coming now I'm
back the Knights pinned
let's go pon mm-hmm I want to keep that
pin we're going to get the rook I got
the rook can't be saved
oh yeah I can not hear it doesn't matter
okay the rooks dead I now come back here
oh my goodness
let me get this Knight he's sitting home
he's sitting home if the knight moves I
get f7 I should just taken it what am i
doing this game is taking a long while I
have ten seconds but it will be enough
it will be enough mate until no matter
what or one back to Charlie 5630
I've been in this position before don't
get overconfident
Kirk Fisher how to play against Fisher
here Kirk the Kirk version of Fisher
Savannah Cobb I almost just played d6
let's do that
darks court maybe just pinpoint that
pond dark square weaknesses kill the
knight he's dead
he cannot be defended night here is also
a threat I'm just getting too clean now
she's toast and the rook might be toast
as well Bishop takes pawn I just react
or just take the Queen actually back to
tyrant they resigned 72 30 30 20 minutes
remaining
okay efore why was i moving right away
in f4 Knight f3 establish upon on e5
meet d5 with the e-file get my knight
right there
the Knight has to move okay let's do
this
and I like my knight right there I want
to get okay let's support this actually
reinforced d4 move my knight other way
develop my lights crab fish I want to do
this because it would just help their
development on if I took my knight I
want to get f5 in vision appear castle
f5 or maybe f5 right away I still might
want to do f5 and I'm going to
do that I'm gonna do a piece sack I want
my knight to be the one that ends up on
f5 and I want to Queens III stuff that's
not happening just drop back for a
second and play b3 let's get this night
out of there so now I have just playing
the F file there's no compensation get
this Bishop out of there although I
can't go backwards now the night is
gonna grab that pawn that is a pain
Knight takes pawn was there got to get
out of that pin okay my opponent helped
me by taking a pinned piece pile up on
the F pop F file 27 seconds drop back
dark square weaknesses why am I not
getting a Bishop to f6 could somebody
tell me that bishop here discovered
stuff the bishop has taken just take
that Knight get to f6 and finally get to
g7 that's what I should have been going
for h6 King h7 is probably be owning the
only Queen here rook up and over
rook up and over Queen to rook takes
pawn there's no defense to it no good
defense it's actually gonna be me this
pawn wasn't there it wouldn't have been
back to term I would have been
independent for t2 34 18 minutes
remaining
how are we doing are we doing my
computer is actually holding up okay the
chess juggler the chess juggler Smith
more gambit let's try d5 this time okay
I'm getting a pawn is that really gonna
turn into a gambit with f3 sort of black
Redeemer ish okay I'm just gonna make
sure I controlled d5 ideally I'd like to
get my light square Bishop out though
with my opponent having more rapid
development I'm going to be content with
developing a queen side with b6 Bishop
b7 let's take this knife first and then
take here I don't want to deal with that
I don't want to deal with that Knight
they're not doing that okay let's just
keep this pawn here let's take this out
and okay I was gonna I'm probably gonna
go here even if Queen recaptured there's
no there's no attack against my King is
there okay I could still play here
my Bishop's there to defend Queen c7 I'm
on the rook I'm looking for a queen
trade as well hang on
just stay active I might I mean my
opponents territory at my base point
covered that's just a free piece hang on
I've dropped pieces before but it's hard
to drop pieces if you are coordinated
and that's what I am right now
I'm coordinated okay this pawn can not
be stopped no catching him no catching
him just grab these guys fast no
stealing it's no steal me
and I here no matter what back to
terminal 159 5648 16 minutes we're not
even halfway there
Oh II for just the third time I'm
putting this guy all right I'm gonna I'm
not gonna hang on to it that was a bluff
yeah you're really crazy to try and hang
on to that at that point I'm gonna kick
this night around though tonight they're
just play out here no matter what the
night's gonna have to retreat if Bishop
takes he's got to go in reverse he's not
going in reverse though he's gotta go in
reverse again otherwise the rook Falls
okay I'm gonna move okay now there's
LightSquared weaknesses keep the knight
in a pin I have my opponent work a
little bit harder to get out of that pin
pinpoint this square and it would come
with a check it is check pin this knight
can also throw my knight into D getting
another piece I'm not the bishop at the
end of it
flight square here no matter what guard
everything here no matter what cut the
King off give a check cut that King off
go here here there's no more pawn moves
cut this King off and then March there's
not gonna be stalemate hang on
just make sure it's check every time and
then that's me back to charming 120 64
59 54 15-minute warning okay no no no no
okay
I played this guy before we're gonna see
okay I'm boxing that night out now
boxing that night out okay let's let's
get a center here it's gonna be quite
difficult as well I think - now Castle
since I could play my Bishop to c5
however there might be a capturing and
Bishop check i Glock with my bishop and
then the bishop has to take as otherwise
there's well now how do you Castle you
got it I'm gonna have two bishops on
these diagonals oh all right I'll go on
castled I'll go on castled one of
pressure on this beep on it's difficult
to defend I have pressure on the night
okay
I'm dry I'm just dropping this part just
dropping that pond on I forget this guy
things are a little bit reckless right
now get my king over here
that Knight can't move just yet okay I
guess I'll just take my bishop finally
developed oh I'm on that rug I was on
that rook that's why they took there I
thought that looked a little weird I was
on that rook on f1 I don't want to move
this pond then the knight comes to life
pressure on this and well now I'm a
little bit no I'll just attack it I have
a fork actually if I did this right away
Knight takes pawn
let's do it now Mike check stop knight
here I should just take that pawn get
rid of that tricky Knight break this
down now
there's no time it's not even gonna
matter not even gonna matter
everything is hit the bishop is pretty
much trapped now their forked no time
back to tournament 140 107 8270 13
minutes 24 seconds remaining okay
whistle whistle
never played this guy okay this is a
scary opponent this is Gary 20 20 25 15
scary what is what is this guy eating
what is this guy eating I need to know
okay uh actually I'm okay to see that I
think I am I get out of that tricky
stuff
okay this is very tough my night needs
to do something here that's a good move
that's a very very good move I need a
flight square I need a flight square oh
boy I'm gonna do a Ponce act just so I
can move my bishop just so I can move my
bishop pawn push I have my bishop there
to defend oh this pawn is dropping move
am I getting that rook what am I missing
where's that move but I have it still
right on that rook that one was easy to
miss that was sneaky oh I have this
covered rook check I could just take
them if I took right there then the
Queen could have taken there I just want
to play hanging on and I open stuff up
my goodness these pawns are gonna be so
dangerous can I get something over here
I need perpetual check or something
that's not even working
where are the checks is this gonna work
out somehow Bishop lock oh I don't have
that it's it's defended oh I forgot that
that was defended oh there's no time
either
how much time
oh my god I wanna turn him also lots my
breath 0.4 I think back to tournament
they resigned dowon 171 27 ha - when oh
my goodness my yet it again upon could
have had taken so many times I thought I
was making that move though for like
time issues like out a night oh oh they
resigned back determine I'm getting
showered with points where were these
gifts in the last tournament okay
how many times I'm gonna capture like
that I can't believe I won that game I
can't believe I won that game Queens
don't jump like that they don't jump
ok let's trade can I get a fork on c2 if
that happens Knight b5 I'm just gonna
take jump up here and I still have a bad
Bishop here he needs to be working night
before though I'm ok if you take this
guy okay he's still bad he's still bad
news
ok pawn advance my knight wants to be
where okay I have activity that was bad
how do I get this that Knights gonna
kill me yeah he's definitely gonna kill
me I have to watch out for a knight move
there
you know the knight right here is gonna
defend everything oh no Knight fork oh
no no no no no no no no no no this guy
is so sneaky this Knight is so sneaky
please don't be a fork please the rook
could give a fork or a rookie give a
check rook check is not good actually
I'm there just in time get out of
checking distance how about that that's
my that's my plan get out of tricky
Forks I get this pawn at least okay I'm
back in the game
I have time advantage to over here came
to defend defend defend keep defending
keep defending throw a check in and then
come back here time burners this pawn
rolling target this pawn in a way so
that the rook cannot defend it time
burner
grab that pawn a check and then go here
there's no time
back to Turman 210 210 147 126 oh man
I'm still kind of having flashbacks of
that game my okay my opponent wasn't
moving there for a second I got nervous
that was my I don't know how what I'm
trying to say again when I go quiet for
a second or two I just I get nervous if
my opponent isn't moving right away okay
pawn push and then Bishop h6 no let me
just threaten aged seven Knights gonna
move back alright let's just go for it I
have a strong Center let's do this first
and then plant my knight right there I
might want to just give him up pawn push
okay no dark squares dark squares age
four and then Bishop g5 this guy is dead
he's not helping he is definitely not
helping okay that's that's still there
he's too good I just don't want to get
rid of him pawn takes a recaptured check
let's do this first I'm on the Queen
with check I was missed my opponent
tried an in-betweener back to tournament
two 3167 146 seven minutes remaining
oh man hanging on DG DG is here we
played a five minute game earlier okay I
was ready to take not gonna take this
time
just have that square supported okay
let's just get more development and more
development I think I have a lead and
development because of those those moves
right there I still believe in
development and I'm gonna get this
break-in is it going to amount to
anything however the night just comes to
f3 to defend h2 just in time now there's
a weakness on this square I'm looking
for a good versus bad
good night versus bad Bishop situations
I have that defended with my night stay
central and actually ok let's do this
jump in here right now I'm on the brook
open stuff up pawn takes got to get rid
of the Queen she's way too strong way
too strong on that Square and okay stop
that pond from going any further drop
back and then actually let me get these
guys going there past that ponds dead I
have this defended and I feel like I
just want to do this so I can get at
that a pond and now he's going it takes
80 no matter what if night here I go
here actually and get a piece they
resigned back determine 250 187 166 5
minutes remaining
ok my goodness my goodness already f4
you've been here before you have
definitely been here before
ok now that could be very awkward
the bishop there's actually a bit
misplaced being on that square cuz d5 is
that much more difficult to get in okay
f5 f5 Bishop h6 Knight g5 after there's
a capture on I'm just doing this as a
clearance I don't I'm not looking to
recapture on F when I do this
specifically just for a clan stirring
move the number one defender of this
kingside Castle position and now I
believe night right here Knight here I
take it
and now there's gonna be mate if the
king takes I'm on h7 it's tough this is
very tough okay so now I'm just gonna
take this
it's a rook and this is dropping
everything is dropping this pawn is
pinned I want to make sure my bishop can
still see Knight here check let's get my
last piece doing something watch out for
the forks I have this square covered I
could've just taken this pawn also I
have a check here get rid of that pond
I'm definitely a check here coming up
everything is hit everything is hit
right now take here with check and then
the Queen next okay and now give a check
with the Queen and then take out these
Knights time is even take out these
nights before it's too late get rid of
the Knights okay now it's much easier I
could rely upon the dark squares attack
pin pieces less than six seconds for my
opponent here no matter what time
burners here no matter what no time back
determine two seventy two twenty seven
three minutes eight seconds this would
be the last game oh look who it is the
one that beat me up last time the one
that beat me up last time I gotta get I
gotta get Dillon back I get Dillon back
here man
F to eat F to to me last time F to Denis
Mia
I gotta get kicked around
what's this knight doing I should just
jumped in there okay I'm on the Queen
I could have hit in the Queen I could've
hit the Queen again I feel like I'm
missing something I'm scared
this is everything to say if I have this
covered okay they should be okay my
knight is a beast on f6 take what the
pond I have the c5 square available I
need to break down this structure time
is even could take this pond also get
rid of that clean get rid of that clean
pod push I take here actually I could
take here I know I did it in the wrong
order
ah I did it in the wrong order
I'm losing again but I have a tricky
night and it's in some ponds I should
have some pressure yeah I have a strong
center actually there is some
compensation their night is out of
bounds here no matter what
rote activity they're down on time as
well
I shouldn't have dropped that by Jeff
Romania ones though watch out for those
matin ones I'm on the bishop actually I
need to I want to trade just a little
bit more so a little bit more oh okay
now everything is okay now the thing is
okay I think just take that Bishop why
am I not taking that bishop now I got
him no time there's no time either no
stalemates they resigned back to
tournament that got a little too scary
less than a minute 57 56 T Knight e4 e
for stop that b5 advance it wasn't being
stopped are they really gonna take I'm
on the knight now oh come on the Queen
clamped down I'm on the night are they
just kitchen sick of me now they're not
back to termite they resigned 3 10 to 25
32 seconds the homestretch the
homestretch is where we are at right now
here we go this one is most likely just
not going to finish right no time 15 14
13 that d5 and they're calling it that's
it
first place confetti finally oh man he
closed out alright good games all three
10 to 25 208